election 2013 what does the ftp want in
the interview ftp leading candidate hina
gorilla her brother live isn't mr.
Padilla we're here in mines in hainan
files your home state would you say it's
a part of the country that's typically
German give you serve as a yob in a
certain way yes because historically
it's been a gateway mass migrations have
taken place here the French Spanish
Romans and Celts have all been here and
the people of minds are a mixture of
them it's a true European region with a
suitable mentality we believe one should
adjust to things and take a cosmopolitan
attitude s'ok Meyer described it best in
his work the mentality the openness
that's a centerpiece of European
development stemming from mines go for
mine selves I'm spawn spawn Germany goes
to the polls in September 20 seconds
after over a decade in opposition you've
been in the governing coalition for four
years have they been good years for
Germany 10 d ID they've been very good
years the world envies Germany and its
economic development the situation here
no other western country is in better
shape than Germany it's because the
people are so hard-working and dedicated
because of our strong social partnership
and the policies of the governing
coalition these positive developments
have proven crucial the world envies
Germany these successes we want to add
another 4 years to the four good years
we've had via pudiera tofu develop in
either torture the world envies Germany
that's true what's being achieved here
has certainly been recognized but German
citizens don't seem to like the ftp
opinion polls indicate you won't get
much more than five percent doesn't that
suggest a rejection of the last four
years well for the latest in few yarra
all right mrs. no wait and see what
happens many voters are still undecided
and fdp voters tend to play their cards
close to their chests in contrast to
supporters of the greens and other
parties
fifth experience shows the greens
perform better in opinion polls than
they do in the elections fdp results are
often better than surveys suggest keep
this stuff why don't people want to
openly express support for the Liberal
Democrats and begin oh yeah is our
victory last time around was so
monumental that there was some
disappointment afterwards we've reduced
taxes for about 22 million people
lowered pension contributions got rid of
extra fees for doctor's visits but there
is a certain mentality involved let's
take the middle class one of the FTPS
target groups my father was a retailer a
lot of people like him are afraid that
if their opinions become known
conservatives will go elsewhere to buy
their underwear and Social Democrats
will buy their socks somewhere else it's
typical of the social structure of ftp
voters that you shouldn't be too open
about your opinion but that's ok ok
dimensional help me to school it's
always better for us when we're high in
the polls sunshine is better than rain
so I'm trying to trade eyes but I'm very
optimistic that we'll do better than
many expect and it's also good for the
party will fight for every single vote
for every single citizen right up until
the very last minute until 6pm on
September 22nd in full gas came ova der
Sturmer eat a burger in when he disposed
fiora for four years the government has
been occupied with the euro crisis has
the euro been rescued and is to Oregons
angus garroted ya mean françoise
basically we have better structures in
place than before I remember when it all
started in Greece we met in the
Chancellery the Chancellor foreign
minister Vesta fella and others every
hour there were announcements from the
Bank of England the German central bank
the Fed the US central bank about what
the euro was up against we had no
instruments we're better prepared now is
you know it pays off we have the ESM
before that we had its predecessor the
EFSF all of them very complicated
mechanisms with strange acronyms and now
we've introduced new
mechanisms solidarity is important but
the recipients of assistance like Greece
must do everything possible to correct
the causes of their misfortune the cause
of Greece's misery is a lack of
competitiveness they're not in a
position to justify their government
spending it's a sensible principle to
give but to expect something in return
good what these are quotes that's key
that's a fact that is taking hold within
the EU look at the progress in Ireland
and Spain they're sticking to a strict
course of austerity Portugal to none of
that would have been imaginable without
these policies we know we need Europe
but we have to do things properly the
visitor Papa this is faced each button
Damac to the markets are being flooded
with cheap money are you worried about
monetary stability it quits least in the
short term no but in the midterm yes
what we're doing now is getting the
economy going no it's there are no exact
figures lunch its but US business news
agency bloomberg estimates that between
25 and 28 trillion dollars have been
printed that's all virtual achieved by a
click of the mouse in Europe about five
billion euros of new money has entered
circulation to keep the economy moving a
lot of it trickles away in the market
because banks no longer trust each other
instead of giving money they don't need
to the bank next door in mid term loans
they give it back to the central bank at
either zero or minimal interest that can
only go on for a short time it has a
flip side think of retirement insurance
think of savers if you get one percent
interest on your savings today you're
lucky that has to be taxed to right now
inflation is at one point six to one
point seven percent that's what said
they makes 50 that will rise soon but
now it's almost expropriation I leave
its fuzzy good life insurance policies
are finding it hard to pay the minimum
interest that's why a policy of cheap
money can't continue indefinitely the US
has already indicated that
even in Europe we can't go on
continuously because we're
disadvantaging private investors and
savors the economy is distorted and we
must get back to normality you're
missing the victor no Molly Tate it so
it should get the stuff is there a time
window for that this come on East often
time you can't tie it down to a specific
day or even year but I'd say we need to
find our way back in the next five years
otherwise printing money will eventually
cause the market economy to malfunction
the free market economy is regulated
through price signals when prices are
high more is produced to put it simply
when prices are low you produce less
because it's not worth it when we make
money artificially cheaper to stimulate
the economy at some point people start
losing the money illusion and decisions
become distorted truth it's going to be
told ya leaves then people turn to real
estate that's happening on a regional
level in some real estate markets here
in the rhine mine region it's
unbelievable the prices being paid
that's not healthy so we've got to
return to normality within the next five
years Nixon Johnson nobody date silicon
disk up Oh at the beginning of the
crisis some people suggested that we
should let countries leave the eurozone
people including some in the ftp we're
talking about controlled bankruptcy do
you believe the eurozone must stay
unchanged or do you think that we can't
eliminate the possibility that a country
may have to leave because it can't
maintain competitiveness Oh most pilots
like the effective of species of Noah
shall distribute it's possible that a
country will have to or want to leave it
can be difficult to adjust Germany
experienced the political consequences
ten years ago with the hearts welfare
reforms maybe pulley Joseph other
countries still have that in front of
them it's not easy to bear the euro has
been seductive when it was introduced
countries like Italy and Greece suddenly
enjoyed lower interest rates instead of
building schools and expanding
infrastructure they increased government
spending now the money's gone the medium
a real estate bubble was created in
Spain and other countries because money
was so
cheap and now come the difficult
adjustments doing something in return
for something hurts when you have to dig
into your own budget and reduce welfare
spending to a minimum a country can
decide it doesn't want to follow that
difficult course and would rather return
to its original currency whether that
would make things easier is another
question because structures would also
have to be adjusted in that case you can
solve structural problems by handing out
money you have to start producing the
right products and investing in research
and development that's the only reality
based solution but countries seeking
that solution have to take action we
don't want to throw anyone out they have
to decide for themselves the Greeks want
to stay in black mr. Pakula you're an
old Seafarer in politics you've got a
few weeks of campaigning to go are you
looking forward to it do you believe the
CDU ftp coalition will win it's being
focused infested I'm firmly convinced we
will win that's supported by the mood
and talk among voters the impression
they're expressing is that we're in a
good situation we've got a government
that's doing a pretty good job why take
a risk now busty Lincoln voted as for
what the Left Party wants an SPD green
coalition is little more than a pipe
dream anyway the left would have to
support it we'd end up like France when
a lawned raise taxes he might as well
have introduced an economic slump and
recession we don't want to return to
past ideals why experiment when we're in
a good place the SPD wants to increase
taxes by 38 billion each year oh yeah he
queried one tomorrow to fly the Greens
to 13 wants 42 billion more right now
Germany is collecting more taxes than
ever before around seven hundred billion
per year the government must learn to
set priorities to live within its means
that's our goal if your incomes limited
you decide what's most important the
government must do that too boys noize
boffin
but the left-of-center parties have just
one thing in mind creating more
government instead of restructuring or
rewarding efficiency they have the great
idea of taking even more money from the
taxpayers and behind that lies another
kind of philosophy a different concept
of freedom we believe people are
perfectly capable of managing their own
money the left things people are too
stupid and must be coerced it reminds me
of the Jacobins who form charities after
the French Revolution to manage people's
money they thought citizens were too
stupid to handle their money I don't
want these guardians of virtue these
kinds of governments I don't want to
have new Jacobins in the form of the
Greens who dictate everything to us up
to what we should eat on Fridays for the
others I'm old enough to eat and drink
as I like and choose how to spend the
money I earn it's a choice between a
free society and outdated socialist
ideals without of course at least
enforced uniform focused on brutha thank
you for talking to us wait thank you